صباح جديد في امريكا ذهب المصوتين الى
صناديق الاقتراع من اجل تجديد دماء
الكونجرس الحزبان الرئيسيان الجمهوري
والديمقراطي يسعى يعني الى الاغلبيه في
مجلس الشيوخ وكذلك النواب نبدا من مجلس
الشيوخ هذا المجلس المكون من 100 عضو الحل
كما ترون 50 مقعدا ليه
الديمقراطيين ومثلها 50 مقعدا للجمهوريين
الان المجلس يجدد مجلس الشيوخ همم يجددوا
نفسه خمسه وثلاثين متعدا في 34 ولايه كما
نشاهد امامها كل الولايات تشهد انتخابات
على عدن واحد ما عدا ولايه اوكلاهما التي
تشهد انتخابات على مقعديها في مجلس الشيوخ
رغم اننا نرى خمسه 35
عدن مطروحا في هذه الانتخابات لكن بعض
المقاعد اهم من بعض المقاعد الاخرى عدد
كبير من هذه المقاعد محسوم لاحد الحزبين
مسبقا الاحمر كما نشاهد بيد الجمهوريين
والازرق كذلك بيد الديمقراطيه يبقى
التنافس في مساحات ضيقه من اجل تحقيق
الاغلبيه الاغلبيه تاتي فقط باحتفاضي خلال
الحزبين بجميع مقاعدهما الحالي وانتزاع
مقعد من الحزب الاخر الولايات التي تضم
هذه المقاعد التنافسيه يطلق عليها ولايات
ساحات المعارك ها هي امامكم كما ترونها
باللون الازرق هي ما يسيطر عليها
الديمقراطيون حاليا
ويريدون الاحتفاظ بها بها اريزونا نيفادا
جورجيا انه هامستر هذه الو هات التي همم
مساحات حرب الولايات باللون الاحمر والتي
نشاهدها همم الان هذه الولايات يسيطر
عليها الجمهوريون ايضا يحاولون الحفاظ
عليها نتحدث عن ولايات مثل فلوريدا نور
كارولينا وكذلك من سلفانيا واوهايو
وسكينسون ويتاه لكن بالنسبه بالنسبه اقل
من طبعا همم بقيه الولاد هنا نضيق هذه
الاحتمالات
اكثر في ولايات ساحات المعارك التي نتحدث
عنها هنا تحديدا ننظر الى هذه همم المعارك
المحتدمه بن سلمان
مقعدها مطروح بعد تقاعد السيناتور
الجمهوريه تومي يتنافس على هذا المقعد
الديمقراطي فيترمان وكذلك الجمهوري محمد
همم الاول
ايضا هناك ولايه اخرى وصراع جديد في
جورجيا الصراع بين همم الديمقراطيه
الحاليه
الانتخابات في هذه الولايه تحمل خصوصيه
شديده طبعا على ذكرها لاحقا في سياق هذه
التقنيه اما المعركه
الاكبر فتكون في صحراء نيفادا بنا
السيناتور الديمقراطيه الحاليه كاثرين
كورتيز ماستو وكذلك الجمهوريه الذي يدعمه
بالتاكيد ترامب ادم
استطلاعات الراي لم تقدم اي شيء مفيد بشان
هويه ال ال الفائز بينهما قد يكون هذا هو
المقعد الحاسب لهذه الانتخابات اذا لبنى
اشهد مفاجات في ولايه اخرى
[موسيقى]